what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I have an absolutely
crazy video for you today this is the
craziest chapter of demons there ever
and we got so much to talk about so make
sure to stay tuned for that if you
enjoyed these Demon Slayer reviews and
want to keep them coming the best thing
you can do is smash that like button and
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification Bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer reviews
remember that you can get early access
to these Demon Slayer reviews by
following anime up poor audio on Spotify
and Apple podcasts or wherever else you
listen to podcasts check out the links
in the description we were actually the
number one trending anime podcast in
Great Britain recently which was very
cool now we just have the rest of the
world left to conquer anyways keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers in
this video I will be talking about the
latest chapter chapter 201 after all
you've been warned now without further
ado let's jump into it I don't think
we've had a chapter title as hype as
this one chapter 201 is called the king
of demons which pretty much breaks all
hype limiters right there remember last
time we were not 100% certain of Tundras
fate he definitely seemed like he was
dead but I mentioned that we didn't see
him cross over so it wasn't final by any
means we're gonna get into detail about
what happened to tundra soon but I'm
sure if you're a Demon Slayer fan you
already know because I was told at least
a million times before I even read this
chapter it's crazy AF and we'll get all
the insane details right after we spend
a little quality time with Mouzon the
man who I've called the demon king of
pop the manga has left out the of pop
part in the title but that's okay since
that'll make more sense by the end of
this chapter we see actual baby Musleh
not giant baby moves on and how death
was always close to him that's
represented by shadowy hands was always
after him his heart stopped numerous
times while he was in the womb so if he
could survive without a heartbeat I
wonder who else could nudge-nudge
wink-wink
for his part baby moves on didn't have a
pulse and wasn't breathing when he was
born he was actually gonna get cremated
but he finally struggled and cried his
way back to life just in time I
absolutely love what the manga is doing
here we know that Mouzon has done such
terrible things but by showing us him as
a frail baby just being saved from
certain death you can't help but
acknowledge his own human frailty and
when we acknowledge frailty and weakness
and others we tend to feel pity perhaps
even some sympathy rather than pure
hatred although I'm sure that some guy
out there will leave a comment about how
much he hates baby Moo's odd however
even people who grow up to do terrible
things were once cute and completely
helpless babies this baby moves on did
nothing wrong yet from a young age he
had to struggle as hard as he could just
to survive and he continued to do that
straight into demon's adulthood the
ultimate lone wolf Mouzon says that what
he strongly desired always came true he
made it happen but he acknowledges that
there is a limit to what one can do
alone Mouzon has to admit that Ubu
ishiki was right all that lives must die
and that only feelings are eternal and
undying Mullen says he doesn't remember
a single human he's killed the flesh
just dies the body disappears but the
feelings were passed on and those
feelings help to defeat the lone wolf
moves on for example just think about
how then Goku helped to inspire the
others especially tangible think about
how you lead she even though he's dead
made all this possible by saving Tommy
oh and passing on his breath of the Sun
and philosophy all the way down to
Tangier Oh everyone's feelings were
passed on and set the subsequent
generations heart ablaze until the
flames were so strong that they burned
Mouzon Busan was even moved by how the
feelings were passed on and we see him
crying
the demon King of Pop himself cries this
is definitely the climax of what I've
been calling the mangakas humanization
of Musa we see this big bad boss being
moved to tears he's powerless his flesh
is about to disappear in the sunlight
forever and then we get the but as we
quickly turned a page we see moves on
play a last-minute reverse uno card of
insane proportions he points out how
it's not just the feeling of the demon
slayers that get passed on muslims
feelings are also undying and eternal
the mind-blowing ly unbelievable happens
moves on entrusts his feelings to tun
jus thus
moves on plans to turn your ichi
successor into his own ironically Mulan
gives us the good news that Tantra is
not dead for good even though his breath
and heart have stopped which is
mirroring how baby Mulan's heart did the
same tundra cells haven't died there's
still time for him keep in mind this is
happening in the past when time zero was
momentarily absorbed into huge baby
moves ons flesh
Akeno style moves on pores all of his
blood and power into kanjiru because he
will conquer the Sun the twist is so
crazy primarily because it makes so much
sense Mulan has planned this out well he
knows that since his sister could
conquer the Sun then time sure probably
can't - he plans for tundra to become
the strongest demon ever the next demon
king he just Mele Otis tangina
who would have thought that the
strongest enemy demon would end up being
our main breaking character you have to
hand it to the mangaka this is some
amazing storytelling Mulan gives all of
his blood to ton zero so it's going to
be much harder if not impossible for
tundra to fight his demon urges tundra
is also a Sun breather to boot he's a
user of the strongest breath style and
currently the strongest Demon Slayer
I don't care if anyone wants to disagree
with that he totally is after what we
saw when he fought against moves on the
strongest living Demon Slayer yo Deecee
successor and our main protagonists
seemingly becomes the final bad guy Wow
and then moves on tells Pancho to make
his dream come true we jump to the
present Demon Slayer members are crying
and then suddenly Tundra wakes up with
demon eyes mind you both eyes because
he's finally healed of his infected eye
I was wondering how they would solve
that problem and here it is Tundra has
become a demon I predicted this might
happen wait earlier in the Mulan fight
and it took longer than expected but we
finally have demon tangelo all of his
skill enhanced by demon blood and what
will be his blood demon art so many
questions Mulan was the demon king of
pop what we'll Tundras demon title be in
the comments I'm asking you to give me a
name to call demon king kanjiru get
creative now we have punch it off who's
been tasked with Mullins dream of
defeating the Demon Slayer core once and
for all his left arm grows back
he goes straight for a demon slayer
member to give shock there isn't a fight
over control right now tundra is in
full-on demon mode right now GU has to
save the demon slayer member keep in
mind there is a lot at stake here
even if Tundra just kills one human
knowing Tundra
if he ever found out that he killed an
innocent person it would devastate him
but not just that as we've seen in the
series demon or not people who kill
innocent people can go to heaven we saw
that with son amis mom even though she
was a demon at the time so Tundras
future on earth and even his future in
the afterlife
are at stake here then we get an image a
Tundra looking very demonic more demonic
that even moves on his Demon Slayer
marks are spreading over his face and
he's salivating through his vampiric
smile he warns another member to get
back but the member has no chance Tundra
is insanely fast arm is about to take
him out except the Sun appears with full
force
Tundra covers himself and begins to burn
now's the moment of truth will he become
immune to the Sun like mezco did and
like Mouzon predicted he would as demon
Tundra suffers GU keeps telling everyone
to get away from him do you who cares so
much about Tundra that he offered to
commit seppuku
if Nezzer ko ever killed a human has to
tell everyone who is still able to fight
to grab a weapon they're going to have
to kill time sure the demon people
around like you Sean's I need to start
to notice that something is not right
then it was the one to say it
Tundra has become a demon he knows Kay
says that they have to keep him under
the Sun and burn him to death he says
this even though we know it must be
ridiculously hard for him to acknowledge
what needs to be done
EU gives clear orders they need to kill
Pandora before he kills anyone as his
friends this appears to be the kindest
thing they can do for him right now
knowing ton zero he'd want them to kill
him too I keep thinking about how Nezzer
ko could be healed and become human
again but in her case she really did
have less moves on blood which allowed
her to overcome him before she even
fully turned back to human so far this
doesn't look like it's going to be
possible with ton zero who seems to be a
complete slave to his demon urges right
now goo is trying to stop him begging
him to die as a human however it's not
to be
the burning stops Musleh hypothesis was
correct
Tantra has arguably become the perfect
life form as Muslim would describe it in
all likelihood he can now recover from
any cuts like mousse on he's immune to
Muslims one weakness the Sun and he
knows the strongest Demon Slayer breath
style not to mention his breath style
should be enhanced by his demon powers
and that he should gain an Opie blood
demon art as well if we're being real
the other guys don't stand a chance
physically they have to somehow reached
on zero and make him give up like what
happened to akasa again this is not
gonna be easy because tendril is given
more moves on blood than anybody else
time zero hits you in the face and he
knows case stops and before he can
finish Kiwa GU has lost a lot of blood
and it's making him dizzy there are less
and less fighters available and the ones
that are are seriously injured keep in
mind we haven't seen eager to and meet
suti cross over yet so they could very
well still be alive
sanam is alive too but we do know that
the strongest pillar of gill may has
passed on and so he can't help them
enos skins i need to try to reach ton
zero talk some sense into him but it
won't work tangel looks like a ferocious
animal he has killing intent in his eyes
and he knows k enzyme you soar in
disbelief what can they do this is the
worst outcome they could have imagined
the sightings who points out how no one
can really fight anymore because they're
so beat up after the moves on fight he
asks Tantra about mezu KO the little
sister he was ready to die for x we'll
only set out on this journey and became
a demon slayer because he wanted to say
his sister and now he might actually be
the one to kill her
the thought is as ironic as it is
depressing pun zero comes at in escape
or to kill we get a flashback of the
three Demon Slayer Musketeers they
agreed in the past that they're like
brothers and that if anyone should stray
from the path the others will stop him
that's exactly what they're dealing with
now tonzura through no fault of his own
has strayed from the path by becoming a
demon it's hard and it's painful pouring
the escape that kill his best friend but
he knows it's the right thing to do does
any to his crying he knows K promises to
strike time zero down but then he
remembers time dose kind face offering
him food he can't do it no matter how
much in awe stay wants to act tough he
can't kill his best friend
he can't connect his sword to Tundras
neck he begins to cry through his bore
mask as demon conjurer goes in for the
kill and that's the end of the chapter
Wow
from a storytelling standpoint this is
one amazing chapter obviously we want a
happy ending and I still think they'll
save Tanja but this was such an exciting
page-turner of a chapter moves on making
tons of his successor the fact that
Tundra is perfect for the job
all of it makes for such good
storytelling what do you think is gonna
happen next
we'll Kundra actually kill someone will
they kill him
or will they find a way to save him like
they say no Zuko before he kills anyone
if they do save him the mangaka found a
way for tundra to successfully recover
his eye and arm perhaps suggesting that
we might get some more adventures with
the demon slang Musketeers when this is
over
after all if daemon tangelo is immune to
the Sun like new Zuko then the human
medicine should work on him too I hope
we get more Demon Slayer it's definitely
popular enough if the mangaka wants to
keep working on it and I hope she does
the fact that moves on wasn't the final
villain and it gives me hope that maybe
we might get some more arcs obviously at
this point this is just wishful thinking
but a man can hope we'll have to wait
and see but no matter what best girl
meets Odie better be okay man anyways
that is it for this mind-blowing intense
chapter I'm curious to see what ton
Joe's blood demon art will be even
though I hope he doesn't actually kill
anyone by using it if you did enjoy this
review make sure to smash that like
button and share this video if you
haven't be sure to subscribe this is
crucial
hit that notification Bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer videos remember
you can get early access to Demon Slayer
and other reviews by following anime up
pro audio on Spotify Apple podcasts or
wherever else you listen to podcasts
find the links in the description a
special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and help make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledge my lord we go sent by sama
himself baby ray and the one tier
patrons the ones will stay on the top
all clans steven grata a lola attempt
though world stealers the school bus
Theisen Kirino a choir respect and
pattaya heffa and our
hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius Anatole kazansky angel Cruz
team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
Ted no Ted Joel - Joel Stanton very
Gucci Alisha actor and a mole 69 Jessica
Calif on emperor otaku JCCC waka and the
coach thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon calm and make up
for and becoming a patron today for as
little as $1 if you do so you'll get
named featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course the
dank memes so check out patreon calm an
amazing kid ascription if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]